pour laborde souvent à l'émission le web
est fertile en arnaques en tout genre
et en cette semaine de la saint-valentin
l'occasion était belle pour explorer
l'univers des arnaques amoureuse elles
font des victimes partout dans le monde
en employant toute une gamme de
stratagèmes que jeff a analysé en
profondeur sur un long temps j'entends
parler de ces arnaques amoureuse là mais
j'ai pas toutes les réponses sur le
fonctionnement sur la méthode qui est
employé comment ça marche
belle sauvageonne de fraude qui se fait
à l'aide des réseaux sociaux donc on va
établir une relation à long terme avec
la victime soit une relation d'amitié
mais plus souvent une relation quand on
gagne graduellement la confiance de la
personne et où au fil du temps là on se
met à dos tu as demandé de l'argent ça
peut s'établir sur les mines donc c'est
vraiment stratagème qui joue vraiment
sur le long terme qui joue aussi sur les
sentiments
donc c'est pour ça que ça devient très
très difficile pour les victimes c'est
qu'elle elle pense avoir une relation de
confiance aux relations très proches
avec quelqu'un est en fait cette
personne n'existe pas c'est un fraudeur
quand j'ai pu lui mon reportage sur les
arnaques amoureuse l'année dernière j'ai
reçu beaucoup de messages de gens qui
jugeait les victimes en se disant
comment comment est-ce que tu peux
croire à ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que les fraudeurs savent exactement
comment trouver les victimes les plus
vulnérables possible est ce qu'on sait
combien ça fait une victime tôt c'est
super difficile à déterminer parce que
justement beaucoup de victimes ne vont
pas dénoncer à la police
ils ont trop honte d'avoir des tomber
dans le piège quand ils se rendent
compte de la fraude c'est le qui se rend
compte que c'était super
donc malheureusement ils sont humiliés
ils se souviendront peut le dire à leurs
familles à leurs ennemis savent à cause
de toutes sortes de problèmes dans leurs
ouvrières relation parce que là de
l'argent disparaît exactement ça peut
détruire puis j'ai parlé une dame en
virginie qui a perdu sa maison
complètement dans un système de fraude
comme ça et quand on dit jeff que ces
gens là tendent un piège
il sait pas n'importe qui n'est pas
aléatoire et j'imagine qu'il ya un type
de victimes en particulier qui vont
chercher donc souvent ils vont aller
dans des groupes facebook pour femmes
qui sont nouvellement veuves ou des gens
qui sont seuls ou des veuves de femmes
militaires par exemple donc ils savent
exactement où trouver des personnes qui
serait susceptible de mordre à l'hameçon
et sait comment se présente ce qui se
présentait donc ils vont créer des faux
profils de personnes qui semblent dignes
de confiance donc aussi des personnes
qui ont une histoire plausible pourquoi
on devrait leur envoyer de l'argent non
par exemple ils vont se présenter comme
je suis un médecin en mission
humanitaire ou bien bon et là je
n'arrive pas à passer la frontière j'ai
besoin d'argent où ils vont se dire vrai
je suis un militant qui est déployée en
afghanistan
j'ai pas assez d'argent pour prendre un
billet d'avion pour venez visiter ma
famille est ce que tu pourrais m'aider
donc qu'ils vont créer des scénarios qui
sont qui sont vraisemblables à la
personne et dans un piège amoureuse elle
pense avoir rencontré une homme sort
d'une personne à qui elle tient et ben
c'est comme ça que je suis à les
manipuler
wes comme une toile d'araignée j'imagine
que ce scénario là ils les répètent ça
marche un endroit avec une personne dont
la bataille ben oui c est on voit même
qu'il ya des gens qui on vole
systématiquement leurs photos dont par
exemple les soldats américains qui ont
des dizaines voire des centaines de faux
comptes qui utilisent leurs photos
c'est précisément ce qui tardait à brian
dany des photos personnelles de cet ex
colonel de l'armée américaine ont été
détournés usurpée et utilisé par près de
3000 faux profils l'objectif abate des
femmes et les entraîner dans un
stratagème coûteux et mal c'est le
colonel dénis a été piqué au vif en
découvrant l'étendue de cette
supercherie
depuis il est en mission il a même
témoigné devant les élus du congrès
américain pour faire la promotion de loi
qui mettrait fin à ce type de fraude
colonel dany quand vous avez réagi au
départ c'est sous choc j'imagine ouest
et j'étais vraiment sous le choc je
savais pas quoi faire c'est inquiétant
de savoir que quelqu'un se fait passer
pour vous vous demander de quelle partie
de votre vie vous avez perdu le contrôle
c'est vraiment inquiétant
j'ai commencé à rapporter ces faux
profil auprès de facebook y en avait
probablement aussi sur d'autres sites
mais c'est d'abord sur facebook que je
voulais mettre un terme à tout ça vous
êtes ensuite colonel impliqué de plus en
plus dans le processus si vous avez même
trouvé une alliée qui nous aident tout
ça nous comment les choses ont évolué
pour vous car cathy me joins de la
californie elle me dit qu'une amie de sa
mère avait été arnaqué pour environ 60
milles dollars par an c'est faux profils
puis elle voulait confirmer que j'étais
bien l'homme sur les photos utilisées
elle a offert de m'aider dans ma
démarche son objectif était vraiment de
rencontrer les gens de facebook et on y
est arrivé au bout d'un an c'est
vraiment une alliée très important pour
moi
elle m'aide à poursuivre ce combat et
combien de temps vous consacrer à cette
cause en ce moment ouais pas mal plus
que je le souhaiterais tu es seulement
pour aller sur facebook chercher des
faux profils de moi et les faire
supprimer ça peut représenter de deux à
trois heures par jour dans mes temps
libres sur ce projet doit uniquement
incroyable et savez vous pourquoi les
fraudeurs vous ont choisi
précisément comme cibles écoute je pense
que c'est très simple sous les premières
photos j'apparaissais en uniforme sur
d'autres j'étais avec mon fils sur notre
ferme avec des chevaux et à partir de
ces images là vous pouvez facilement
invente une histoire pour piéger les
gens et c'est ça qui me bouleverse le
plus j'ai passé une bonne partie de ma
vie à me battre pour ceux qui ne
pouvaient pas se défendre eux mêmes
aujourd'hui mais les photos sont
utilisés pour abuser de ces gens il
s'agit souvent de femmes qui ont vécu
des moments difficiles qui ont perdu un
fils un mari ou un frère au combat et
qui veut aider un soldat qui déployait
l'autre bout du monde et ces fraudeurs
là en profite et cannelle dany dietmann
chose comment vous avez réagi en voyant
que l'image de votre fils de votre
propre fils avait été utilisée par les
fraudeurs
vous savez parfois je me demande combien
de temps encore j'ai envie de faire tout
ça ici ça donne vraiment des résultats
je vous dis à chaque fois que je crois
être en train de perdre ce combat là je
regarde les photos de mon fils qui l'ont
utilisé il ya aussi cette photo d'un
vaisseau dedans atterri à arlington ils
ont utilisé une photo de moi devant sa
tombe et ça me rend furieux et alors il
est hors de question à cause de tout ce
que j'abandonne à givet à 100% je suis
ici à new york j'ai une autre vue de
même atteint je vous parle aujourd'hui
via skype
j'y vais vraiment à 100% à mon colonel
dany c'était très important pour nous de
vous entendre sur tout ce qui vous est
arrivé et sur le type de solution qu'on
peut mettre de l'avant pour stopper ces
fraudeurs vraiment merci beaucoup
un texte